elle avait déclaré qu'elle se battrait
jusqu'au bout et pourtant elle a jeté
l'épongé les critiques et les sondages
défavorables ont eu raison de la dame de
fer margaret thatcher annoncé sa
démission
ils sont trois à se disputer la
succession michael heise online le
tombeur de maguide jeunes majeurs 1 7
chiens déclarés et douglas hurd un
diplomate très british
verdict mardi
claude bez a perdu la partie le
président des girondins de bordeaux a
été démis de ses fonctions est inculpé
notamment d'escroquerie et d'abus de
confiance
il a été libéré sous caution son fils
éric a lui aussi été inculpés
le copain en france avoué c'est lui qui
aurait tué vincent 12 ans hier le corps
de l'enfant a été retrouvé près de trois
mois après sa disparition à sedan il
pourrait s'agir d'un crime sexuel
une seconde personne un indicateur a été
inculpé et écroué
bonsoir la dame de faire baisser sa
garde
après onze ans et demi de pouvoir sans
partage margaret thatcher a démissionné
ce matin une démission à l'image du
personnage avec surprise mais sans
concession maggie est parti sans
attendre le deuxième tour des élections
du parti conservateur parti pour ne pas
être rogné nathalie et heures fastes
discret et dignité tout britannique
keane gamme palace accueille il ya
quelques heures la nouvelle de la
démission de la dame de fer la très
honorable margaret thatcher informe la
reine qu'elle n'a pas l'intention de
disputer le second tour des élections
elle démissionnera de son poste de
premier ministre dès qu'un nouveau chef
du parti conservateur aura été élu
parfaitement sereine dans la défaite
magee a forcé l'admiration cet après
midi à la chambre des communes
vêtu de son tailleur bleu favori elle a
répondu avec aisance et même avec humour
aux questions des députés
reste que cette émission à tous les
aspects d'un coup de théâtre si l'on se
réfère au caractère fonceur et
intransigeant de maggie hier encore le
premier ministre annonçait son intention
de se battre jusqu'au bout pour gagner
le premier tour de ces élections a été
un révélateur près de la moitié des
députés conservateurs ont voté contre la
lutte de leur leader hier matin à la
presse britannique était plus que
pessimiste et bon nombre de
conservateurs auraient conseillé à
madame thatcher de jeter l'épongé
c'est aujourd'hui chose faite après onze
ans et demi de règne sans partage maggie
s'en va a chassé par sa propre famille
il lui reste cependant une consolation
avoir battu un record et pas n'importe
lequel celui de longévité au 10 downing
street
détesté ou admirer margaret thatcher n'a
jamais laissé les britanniques
indifférent ces derniers temps les
sondages et c'est très dur pour la dame
de fer
mais son départ provoque évidemment un
choc au sein de la population
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux dans
l'avion pour londres et à londres
philippe pisteurs et bernard banques 15
heures direction londres quelques
britanniques sont dans l'avion
leurs journaux dépassé par l'événement
la surprise du nord date maggie vous
sélectionnez non c'est vrai c'est
incroyable
non
la smac
je suis très surpris avec tout ce
qu'elle a déclaré ces derniers jours
dix ans qu'elle se battrait jusqu'au
bout viennent mais personnellement je
sens que c'est mieux pour le dit c'est
bien la voir partir pour les hommes
n'est ce pas pour le parti conservateur
je pense que le pays s'en tirera mieux
sans elle
jason donovan le chanteur ne se pique
pas de politique
son mentor est à côté alors no comments
je suis vraiment vraiment désolé que
margarita tueur de démissionner il n'y a
qu'une chose qui ne me plaisait pas
c'était la pole tacle south kensington
agnew titre laconique des journaux du
soir
thatcher par co2
ça c'est une bonne nouvelle ouais
pourquoi je n'ai jamais fait ça
kel away si ce stade parce que c'était
un véritable homme d'état
c'était assez l'international toulon
lisez ça si c'est la grande bretagne
mais savent je suis triste pour mon
emploi cela représentait pour contrer
michael heseltine l'homme par qui le
tumulte est arrivé de fidèles de maggie
se sont présentés pour ce second tour
mardi prochain dauga third le ministre
des affaires étrangères et john match
celui des finances celui des trois qui
l'emportera sera automatiquement premier
ministre ce qui est sûr ce soir c'est
que le 10 downing street aura bientôt un
nouveau locataire
on a regardé ou margaret thatcher
quittera donc le 10 par la suite dans
quelques jours c'est à dire juste après
l'élection du nouveau leader des
conservateurs
trois candidats donc pour ce poste à
haut risque michael the times l'homme
qui a fait vaciller la dame de fer mais
aussi john major et douglas hurd clément
weill raynal a effeuillé le uss
britannique pour savoir qui ils sont
premier candidat michael heseltine 57
ans le tombeur de maggie michael
heseltine ou l'ambitieux fortunés tout
petit déjà il voulait être premier
ministre il l'avait marqué dit on a
vingt ans sur son journal intime sorti
d'oxford il a un premier projet faire
fortune pour pouvoir se lancer ensuite
dans la politique il fait fortune dans
l'édition et l'immobilier rentrer à la
chambre des communes en 66 gravi les
échelons s'oppose à margaret cette chère
il la trouve trop autoritaire elle le
trouve trop ambitieux mais elle le prend
quand même dans son gouvernement à
l'environnement puis à la défense il
démissionne en 86 son surnom cet argent
deuxième prétendant douglas hurd 61 ans
le pragmatique européen
diplomate de carrière il a attendu
l'année dernière pour devenir secrétaire
au foreign office
il a fait l'essentiel de sa carrière
avec margaret cette chère il a de l'avis
général montrer sa stature d'homme
d'état dans sa gestion de la crise du
golfe il parle le chinois a écrit des
romans de politique fiction il a cinq
enfants de deux mariages troisième
candidat john major 47 ans parti de rien
il est devenu chancelier de l'échiquier
son père était trapéziste dans un cirque
il a quitté l'école à 16 ans démarre
comme chômeurs se passionne pour le
cricket
ils échouent à l'examen d'entrée des
chauffeurs de bus aujourd'hui c'est un
économiste libéral qui fait autorité
dans la city son meilleur coup avoir
convaincu maggie de faire rentrer la
livre dans le serpent monétaire européen
déterminé même parfois un tenace
margaret thatcher avait imprimé sa
marque dans la politique britannique dès
les premiers mois une politique sans
concession et sans compromis menée
tambour battant pendant plus de dix ans
des malouines à la grève des mineurs de
l'europe à la crise du golf de 79 à la
démission portrait sylvie levey hélas
son canton elle n'est pas encore la dame
de fer pas même micheal dans le coeur
des britanniques
nous sommes le 11 février 75 miles
hachey fait son entrée en politique
puisque son parti celui des
conservateurs vient de la choisir comme
leader dans l'industrie
quatre ans plus tard ce match devient
premier ministre et du même coup c'est
l'angleterre qui bascule du côté des
conservateurs
c'est aussi le début des privatisations
les malouines un archipel du bout du
monde envahi par les troupes argentines
un jour d'avril 82 que la dame de fer va
reconquérir à coups de canon une poêle
qui va payer puisqu'elle son vainqueur
des élections en 82 pour autant à
l'intérieur du royaume la situation ne
cesse de se gangrener mars 84 les
mineurs font grève ils essaieront en
vain d'empêcher la fermeture d'une
vingtaine de mines brighton le 12
octobre
meg échappe de justesse à un attentat
signé l'ira l'armée républicaine
irlandaise
plus récemment l'hiver dernier un vent
de mécontentement a soufflé contre le
nouvel impôt local la poll tax en
matière de politique étrangère enfin on
retiendra surtout l'axé washington long
du fameux coup maggie granny et puis la
halle inverse le peu d'empressement de
la dame de fer pour construire l'europe
une robe qu'elle n'aura douté pendant
onze ans et qui lui coûtera à la tête de
quelques ministres qui démissionnons
pour cause d'avoir préféré la cea magill
une maggie inflexible qui depuis se
mettent en pourtant ne peut plus signer
le v de la victoire au 10 downing street
dès l'annoncé de la démission de
margaret thatcher la bourse de londres a
réagi et paradoxalement elle est
fortement hausse avec un bond de 33
points
il faut dire que la politique économique
de margaret thatcher était très contesté
intransigeance rigueur manque de
souplesse une politique très impopulaire
pour des résultats médiocres constat
avec bernard ségara
l'histoire retiendra que la dame de fer
aura permis l'accouchement d'une
économie moderne mais de façon
autoritaire avec un coût social très
élevé la pole taxes en étant la dernière
illustration
sous son règne l'appareil de production
a été modernisé les retards de
croissance et de productivité rattraper
margaret thatcher aura favori y ait à la
fois l'avènement des classes moyennes et
du secteur tertiaire dans l'industrie
des emplois ont diminué tandis que dans
les bureaux il se multipliaient son plus
grand échec la régulation du marché de
l'emploi
malgré tous ses efforts pour affaiblir
les syndicats le chômage et l'inflation
d'origine salariale haute à des niveaux
record je crois que ce dont a besoin
l'économie britannique maintenant c'est
d'avoir à la tête de sa politique
une personne qui sera à même de régler
par le consensus de plus large possible
les différents conflits qui apparaîtront
aujourd'hui avec 11 % d'inflation un
million sept cent mille chômeurs une
croissance négative des taux d'intérêt
très élevés et une livre six ferme
qu'elle pénalise les exportations
l'économie britannique a désormais
besoin d'une gestion plus sociale et
plus proche de celle de ses partenaires
européens
la dame de fer croyez au privé ont
marché et au libéralisme à outrance
les anglais sont préférés un libéralisme
à visage plus humain impopulaire ces
derniers mois en grande-bretagne la dame
de fer était ou plutôt se faisait
respecter dans les relations
internationales elle est saluée ce soir
par françois mitterrand qui affirme
qu'elle a marqué l'histoire de son pays
et l'europe l'europe encore avec
l'hommage de jacques delors et pourtant
la résistance farouche de la dame de fer
vis-à-vis de l'europe était légendaire
réaction à strasbourg au sein du
parlement européen
reportage de françois poulet mathis au
parlement européen c'était le choc ce
matin
maggie thatcher victimes de sa politique
européenne l'événement est d'importance
dans tous les groupes politiques de
réaction est essentielle
c'était une grande dame un acteur
irremplaçable du paysage européen
mais c'est peut-être aussi s perdons le
signe d'un changement significatif de la
politique britannique
silence prudent chez jacques delors on
ne commande pas at il fait savoir un
événement politique intérieure
britannique pour les députés anglais
c'est le signe d'un déblocage les
politiques
madame thatcher bello leur était pour
moi pas suffisamment fort pour l'union
européen le problème avec pas le cas et
qu'elle pensait du nôtre
politique sur l'europe elle pensait
d'avoir pour l'élection prochaine en
angleterre en grande bretagne une
politique de peut-être les engagements
de la communauté
et ça c'était de problème pour le parti
parlementaire à vendre même pour nous
ici à strasbourg par un changement de
base changement de style oui
certainement mais au fond je ne crois
pas que l'émission est animée mais
monsieur médias pourrait finalement
changer les intérêts fondamentaux de
royaume-uni changement de fond ou
changement de style aujourd'hui à
strasbourg
le sentiment était néanmoins que quelque
chose d'important venait d'arriver en
angleterre en france au mas de françois
mitterrand donc hommage plus mitigé de
pierre mauroy il affirme que cette
démission marque avant tout l'échec
d'une politique
margaret thatcher est en revanche
l'argument largement saluée par jacques
chirac
pierre méhaignerie mais aussi valérie
giscard d'estaing cher aura été avec
winston churchill le plus grand ministre
britannique des 50 dernières années
le rideau tombe sur la dame de fer elle
a droit
je crois à nos applaudissements
je souhaite que ce soit aussi l'occasion
pour la grande bretagne de s'engager
davantage dans la construction
européenne l'union de l'europe à
laquelle nous travaillons attend
maintenant la contribution britannique
le plus vibrant hommage à margaret
thatcher a été rendue aujourd'hui par
george bush le président américain qui
rendait visite aux gi's installé en
arabie saoudite dans le cadre de
l'opération bouclier du désert
george bush qui restait très ferme
vis-à-vis de saddam hussein en réclamant
la libération de tous les otages tout de
suite un voyage tout de même dans la
tradition américaine 5 skilling days en
plein désert avec barbara bush dans le
rôle de la marraine des boys pierre
babette hinx kings oblige dinde rôtie
obligatoire pour tout le monde
george bush a partagé le menu des
militaires et des gi's en plein désert
saoudien dans ce que les soldats
américains appellent
ce que deux vallées parce que cette
dépression est à portée de missiles
irakiens
c'est peut être pourquoi aussi le couple
présidentiel portait une tenue militaire
battle dress de camouflage pour barbara
pantalon kaki chemise bleue aviation
pour georges vins chill photo de groupe
autographes et propos musclés tout aussi
obligatoire pour cette tournée des
popotes trois raisons majeures pour
lesquelles nous sommes là avec nos
alliés de l'onu en tenant ce terrain en
défendant la paix la liberté
nous sommes ici pour défendre la liberté
défendre notre avenir défendre des
visites au sens nous ne sommes pas ici
pour un exercice
ici c'est une véritable situation de
crise et ne repartiront pas avant
d'avoir rempli notre mission avant que
les envahisseurs ne soit partie du
koweit et c'est pour ça que vous êtes
ici au total de georges bush aura passé
sept heures au milieu de ses troupes
assez pour irriter bagdad trop peu pour
surmonter le blues des gi's dans le même
temps les libérations d'otages continue
une centaine d'entre eux ont quitté
bagdad aujourd'hui de les deux
délégations l'une suisse et l'autre
conduite par jean marie le pen qui
atterrit à mulhouse avec 70 ex otages le
numéro un du front national qui s'est
une nouvelle fois démarqué de la
position occidentale en affirmant que la
seule solution que seule une solution
négociée était possible reportage fr3
strasbourg commentaires jean marc pitte
dure journée pour jean marie le pen le
succès de son voyage à bagdad a été
assombri par quelques péripéties il
voulait atterrir à strasbourg pour
souligner le caractère européen de sa
démarche
le boeing 727 des iraqi airways s'est
finalement posé sur l'aéroport de bâle
mulhouse
pour le chef du front national cette
embûche n'a rien d'accidentel
elle constitue une injure à l'égard d'un
gouvernement étranger qu'il souhaitait
faire un geste en direction du parlement
européen
en choisissant strasbourg capitale de
l'europe elle dénonce d'un véritable
prise d'otages les passagers de cet
avion détourné de sa destination
commerciale où l'attendaient les
familles et les amis des otages libérés
il s'agit d'une entrave cynique à la
libre circulation des personnes
jean-marie le pen a affirmé que 85 visa
lui avait été accordée par les autorités
iraniennes pour le départ d'otages
il était finalement 70 ressortissants de
neuf pays européens
le président du front national a mené
cette mission à la tête d'une délégation
de députés des droites européennes
à l'issue de ce voyage il accuse
certains pays de laisser volontairement
des otages sur place semble que certains
gouvernement voudrait bien conserver la
base des otages de façon à pouvoir s'en
servir comme argument pour le
déclenchement d'une guerre pour
augmenter encore la rancoeur de jean
marie le pen son arrivée au parlement
européen est passée inaperçue
la tension lui a été dérobé par la
démission de mam satcher football et
affaires interdit de gestion inculpé
d'escroquerie de faux et usage de faux
entre autres claude bez n'est plus ce
soir le président des girondins de
bordeaux
il entraînait avec lui dans la tourmente
l'un de ses deux fils inculpé lui aussi
la famille baez et les girondins c'était
une longue histoire mais peut-être aussi
une histoire de fausses factures ou
mauvaise gestion baez s'en va la justice
tranchera
jean-philippe dire la dernière image de
claude bez avant son inculpation
c'était hier soir à l'issue du conseil
d'administration extraordinaire des
girondins ou des dispositions ont d'ores
et déjà été prises pour assurer leur
avenir immédiat
8h20 ce matin ericb st jacques rubio le
patron de la société mallardo arrive au
palais ils sont entendus à propos des
travaux du haillan et de l'ancien siège
du club
une heure plus tard c'est au tour de
pascal baisse est de rendre et pensant
pdg d'aquitaine environnement de les
rejoindre
ils repartent libre en fin de matinée
peu de temps après l'arrivée de claude
bez claude bez qui est interrogé durant
plusieurs heures par le juge bernadette
pragout au terme de l'information
judiciaire ouverte le 10 août dernier
peu après 13h ericb st jacques rubio
quitte le palais à leur tour
aucune information n'est alors
communiquer aux environs de 14 heures
claude bez sort du bureau de bernadette
pragout en compagnie de ses avocats
quelques minutes plus tard un communiqué
du procureur de la république signifie
que claude bez est inculpé d'escroquerie
d'abus de confiance de complicité de
faux et de recel d'abus de biens sociaux
il reste en liberté sous caution mêmes
chefs d'inculpation pour son fils éric
jacques rubio lui est inculpé de faux et
usage de faux
le tout sur fond de scandale immobilier
près de trois mois après sa disparition
le corps du petit vincent 12 ans a été
retrouvée près de sedan enterré dans un
bois proche de l'endroit où il avait
disparu son meurtrier
un adolescent de 15 ans a avoué il a été
inculpé avec un homme de 37 ans il était
depuis le début de la sphère les
principaux suspects reportage à reims de
valérie preto si qu'ici dans le grès du
fond de givonne que le corps de vincent
de cours a été retrouvé hier les amas de
branchages dans un talus situé à une
centaine de mètres du sentier un secteur
qui avait été ratissé au moins deux fois
par le bénévole lors des recherches mais
ici personne n'a jamais rien remarqué et
ya passé chez eux pendant trois quatre
jours des 3 400 personnes
les branches du châtelet ive et jusque
là donc lacunes
c'est également dans ce secteur que les
vêtements de vincent avait été retrouvée
disperser 1 1 sur plus de 300 mètres
c'est un mineur un voisin de vincent qui
a craqué dans le bureau du juge
d'instruction
ces aveux ont permis de découvrir le
corps c'est lui qui avait été gardé à
vue pendant 40 heures juste après le
drame avec un autre individu
antoine kogas e psychothérapeute de 37
ans avait habité ici à sedan il y a
quelques années sa mère tenait un
commerce de fruits et légumes lui avait
ouvert un dépôt vente depuis deux ans
antoine corver à vider à paris avec le
mineur ce soir on ignore encore les
circonstances du drame les enquêteurs
n'excluent pas l'hypothèse d'un crime
sexuel une piste qui sera peut être
confirmé demain par les résultats de
l'autopsié
incarcéré et inculpé d'enlèvement
d'enfants les deux hommes seront à
nouveau entendu par le juge
d'instruction
les crédits débloqués par le
gouvernement pour les lycéens vont aller
en priorité au lycée professionnel ce
sont en effet les plus délabrés à
charleville mézières au l'ept du malaise
c'est vraiment son nom
les élèves charpentier plombiers maçons
ont voulu ravaler les façades mais les
bonnes intentions ne suffisent pas ils
se sont heurtés à l'administration
reportage sur place de michel barthen
lycée professionnel armand-malaise 800
élèves il prépare ses apps et bep et bac
professionnel essentiellement dans les
métiers du bâtiment
pourquoi les élèves de l'établissement
il suivi le mouvement de grève début
novembre
la réponse la voici en trois exemples
dans le dortoir
chambrée sont trop grandes rien de
personnel alors ça c'est l'étoile est
d'avoir dans l'écusson ça c'est pas le
pied il y en ad autres sentir mais enfin
ils sont fermés
disons que surtout les toilettes qu'on a
ici on a trois ouvert on a un lavabo qui
est ya pas de chez tri alors travail et
pourtant la chance du lycée malaise
c'est le savoir faire des élèves futurs
menuisiers peintres chauffagiste ou
encore maçon il travaille en réel dans
le cadre de leur formation
d'où cette idée pour sortir de
l'ambiance grève
on a proposé de refaire nous mêmes le
lycée enfin refaire ce qui à refaire on
a proposé que les peintres face les
façades les couvreurs phase qui va pas
sur les toits les maçons pareil et en
chauffage et plomberie refaire donc
toutes les tuyauteries tout ce qui va
pas et on nous a refusé si nous restons
tout de même l'établissement
d'enseignement avec des exigences
pédagogiques
on ne peut pas concevoir qu'un élève
aura à faire une façon répétitive
pendant un temps très long
la même tâche ce sera au détriment
justement de l'objectif pédagogique
poursuivi quoi qu'il en soit ici un pas
a été franchi d'un côté la
responsabilisation des lycéens de
l'autre la prise de conscience de leurs
problèmes par l'administration
un conseil des délégués d'élèves vient
d'être mise en place peut être
permettra-t-il à tous d'avancer dans la
même direction
elle est belle très belle elle est très
photogénique
elle c'est une des stars du mois de la
photo catherine deneuve donne avait
exposé en 24-36 noir et blanc aux
couleurs pavillon des arts à paris
spectateurs admiratifs michel vial
où
vous avez choisi vous même si photo avec
l'équipe de studio magazine comment vous
les avez choisi comment dire d'une façon
forcément par mis trend mais j'espère un
choix un choix très personnel je dirais
un album de famille professionnelle
je crois que j'ai pas beaucoup
d'indulgence pour mon image d'avoir
parce que je la côtoie tous les jours
vous savez bien que le quotidien tué à
peu près tout et parce que j'aime j'aime
pas trop beau en photo comme j'aime pas
trop me voir dans les films c'est un peu
pareil je trouve qu'on sent la
différence quand on regarde l'objectif
d'un photographe qu'on connaît ou d'un
photographe qu'on ne connaît pas assez
les photographes disons que c'est
l'image arrêter ça fait partie de la vie
de deux des acteurs je peux pas dire que
j'aime ça mais je peux pas dire non plus
que j'aime pas ça mais il faut que ce
soit là parce que ça confie mais ça
concrétise quelque chose qui doit
exister quand on arrive quelque part
bien mais il faut que ça aille vite
parce que sinon c'est vrai que c'est un
peu comme toutes ces choses qu'on aime
moi j'aime bien ce qui est fort et léger
vous arrivez à analyser le la
fascination que vous exercez sur le
public l'élan du public vers vous non
j'ai vous savez c'est comme un gâteau
je prends je le mange sur sa délicieux
mais je veux pas analysé le
le plaisir et je pense que ça reste faut
que ça reste comme ça il faut que ça
reste une chose naturelle ça ne peut pas
ça c'est fait et puis ça peut des spurs
et c'est un soufflé tout autre chose
mais pour être complet les rapports du
tiercé quarté + qui se courre est
aujourd'hui à vincennes pour le tir si
ça jouait le neuf le vin et le 5 qui
rapportent dans l'ordre 7125 160 et dans
un ordre différent 1072 francs 20 pour
le quarté + le neuf le vin le 5 et le 2
qui rapportent dans l'ordre 49 1924
francs 80 et dans un ordre différent
2007 130 francs 40
voilà dans quelques secondes istres à 20
heures tout de suite les titres du 19/20
huguette elle avait déclaré qu'elle se
battrait jusqu'au bout et pourtant elle
a jeté l'épongé les critiques et les
sondages défavorables ont eu raison de
la dame de fer
après onze ans et demi de raï margaret
thatcher a annoncé sa démission
ils sont trois à se disputer la
succession michael heise all time le
tombeur de maguide jeunes majeurs un sac
chez rien déclarer et douglas hurd un
diplomate très british
verdict mardi
george bush dans le désert saoudien il
rend visite à ses gi's le président a
exigé la libération immédiate de tous
les otages
il a rappelé que les soldats américains
ne partiront pas avant d'avoir libéré le
koweït
claude bez a perdu la partie le
président des girondins de bordeaux a
été démis de ses fonctions est inculpé
notamment d'escroquerie et de biette
d'abus de biens sociaux
il a été libéré sous caution son fils
éric a lui aussi été inculpés voit la
fin de cette édition le prochain rendez
vous avec l'information c'est à 22h25
soir 3 présenté par marc hautement dans
quelques secondes la météo complète de
michel pourrait à demain 19h bonsoir